[Music]
the last two decades have marked an era
of ambitious school reform so after all
of that work our America's schools
better there is some evidence of
improvement over much of that period the
share of students proficient on state
tests rose one to two percent each year
meanwhile graduation rates skyrocketed
so far so good the problem test results
and graduation rates are subject to
manipulation by the same state officials
who take credit for the results in fact
when compared to national data it turns
out that state reported test gains
outpaced nationally reported gains by 50
to over 100 percent meanwhile the
international data show that between
2000 and 2015 US test scores were
stagnant as was our international
ranking in short the most credible
numbers show the least evidence of
progress you can debate why we've seen
these disappointing results but
proposals for 2020 and beyond should
start with an honest reckoning do you
think America's schools have gotten
better since the year 2000 let us know
in our poll also let us know what other
topics you'd like our scholars to cover
in 60 seconds and be sure to LIKE and
subscribe for more research and videos
from AEI